so Michael did you get to keep this
super creepy doll I want to show
everyone this doll
yeah yes our daughter that's our
daughter Kelly I have adopted that super
creepy doll
um she lives with me now uh no no no no
I no we no I left her behind uh yeah
very creepy sticky doll it would have
just been fun if you you took it though
and then you kept it like in your guest
bedroom for when people came over like
randomly in a corner it'd be nice to
have a guest bedroom
nice Flex Kelly
I just you know why I went there is I
stayed at um that's gonna sound like a
flex too I stayed at someone's house
it was Reba and I set it up and she had
a she had a doll though it was just this
doll and it was so creepy to me I just
dolls are creepy to me and it was maybe
a family thing I don't know what it was
but then like two days later she's like
so we found the doll in the closet and
I'm like oh my God I'm sorry I didn't
put it back it scared me and I couldn't
sleep I was just like I'm not gonna
sleep that thing looking I've done that
at airbnbs I've had that happen at
airbnbs they had something very creepy
and I can't look at it and I know she
was like did you put my stuff in the
closet I was like I kind of did I did I
did I'm so sorry I should have brought
it back out anyway I took some ties you
know see yeah klepto I like it yeah yeah
some of Joel's ties their vintage ties
and oh that's really cool yeah so I took
about 20 of them I mean speaking of that
though the vision should move back I
know I'm sorry I I hope Don is a cow's
guard costume designer is not watching
but yes I have them for you costume it's
incredible this show that's why the
acting is so impeccable the writing is
great the storytelling the Wardrobe the
art Department that makes all those you
just really feel like you're there in
time speaking of custom design it's so
cool like it's such a great team you're
into that's why I know you're crying at
8am because it's it's a great team and
that doesn't always happen like it
doesn't it was yeah it was a rare rare
thing
[Music]
thank you